all right we're getting started we're a
little bit earlier than usual today so
welcome back to another installment of
hi data for those of you who are new
welcome to your first one and everybody
else welcome back as always we like to
acknowledge some of our sponsors so we
like to thank an unfocused for our
sponsoring this event let's meet up TD
Ameritrade for sponsoring the space in
the venue and also - - University at the
University of Michigan for sponsoring
the food technically today is our one
year anniversary so you might have
noticed that cake sitting on key points
for those of you are new emergency exits
there's one right over here and then to
the right of the door that you entered
through as always they're soliciting for
speakers so if you'd like to give a talk
next month is an opportunity that we got
to that and as always we're looking for
feedback to things that we're doing
right things that we're doing wrong
these feel free to let us know you can
always follow everything that we're
doing or find a speaker decks on our
github page and especially for the
respect a voice of our speaker please
hold your questions until the end unless
they're quick
and we'll probably try to keep the time
for questions a little bit shorter today
because our speaker needs to catch a
flight at about 8:25 so let's let's hope
that the weather is gonna hold up for us
here and also remember that you're in a
borrowed space please do clean up after
yourself and we'll be doing cake
afterwards I'd like to always our patio
decor conduct so upon unit is dedicated
to providing a harassment free meeting
experience for everyone regardless of
gender sexual orientation gender
identity and expression disability is
appearance body size race or religion we
do not tolerate harassment of many
participants in any form all
communication should be appropriate for
professional audience including people
of many different backgrounds sexual
language and imagery is not appropriate
for any of our events be kind to others
do not install the foot down other
attendees behave professionally remember
where that harassment and sexist races
or exclusionary jokes are not
appropriate for high data attendees
violating these rules may be asked to
leave the meetup at the sole description
libido organizers but basically don't be
a jerk right we try to go for it but so
but thank you for making this an
inviting environment for everybody a
quick little icebreaker so that you meet
somebody hopefully either turn to
somebody on your left or your right
introduce yourself and say if you owned
a pet growing up and if not maybe why
[Music]
I
all right we're back thank you so I just
point out in it is the badness so on
this month in data science tableau is
running a competition to print read
predict the n-c-double-a both men's and
women's practice so you might want to
get on there there's a $50,000 prize
money also at TD Ameritrade their team I
Logan all swim over there his team is
hiring a data scientist data analyst and
a Java flash mobile developer as well as
there's a from dancing ena science guys
here in Ann Arbor sequel server
developers in Dearborn and Orange County
California and a few developer in New
York City and an SS is empowered the AI
developer the airborne so if anybody is
looking for something to know someone
who is please send them my way my name's
Ben thanks a lot and you want to blow up
your and to Logan recognized here and of
course plug in the next event we're
gonna have do our lightning talks again
so last October we had our first round
of lightning talks where people in the
community here could come out and give
me talk or probably gonna tighten it up
and do seven minute talks and we're
gonna have the first six people who sign
up be giving a talk so look up for the
registration for that both to give a
talk in to attend and that is going to
be taking place on that Tuesday April
10th and then without further ado I'd
like to introduce our speaker today we
have Holden Terrell who is both you know
prolific in the data science space as
well as similar to many of our speakers
here an author of
the books on spark O'Reilly books on
spark so let's give her a round of
applause thank you
and I just put a Linux off top in to
suspend so let's all hope that it comes
out yeah oh okay cool yeah that works
let's call it working yeah cool so this
is a fast introduction to spark now with
vectorize UDF's yay dr. oz UDF's are
exciting if you would like your code to
go fast or you just want an excuse to
rewrite everything it's it's pretty
great this microphone so it picks up a
little less of my movement yeah so my
name is Holden preferred pronouns are
she or her it's tattooed on my wrist and
kiss anyone forgets it's very handy in
the mornings and I am on the spark PMC
you can think of it as being like a
committer except it's kind of like a
shitty version of tenure I can't get
fired but I don't get paid
so that's or I could get fired it would
be a lot of work previously I worked at
a bunch of different companies most of
its Big Data a lot of it was search and
recommendation problems and I'm a
co-author of these two O'Reilly books
there's one of them here today actually
high-performance spark and you can
follow me on Twitter if you want in
addition to Who I am professionally I am
trans queer Canadian and part of the
leather community and this is just a
reminder that we all come from different
backgrounds and as as the introduction
said we should be nice to each other
regardless of where we come from and I'm
actually here on a work visa and I
really hope you all keep those anyways
without further ado I'm hoping you're
nice people I am actually really curious
how many people use spark
that is some how many people are like
vaguely interested in spark cool how
many people don't really care about
spark like that's totally legit okay one
no it's it's cool we will look at some
interesting distributed system stuff in
general and you don't have to use spark
it's quite all right my employer makes
money by selling compute time they don't
really care what you run so we're gonna
talk about what spark is yeah we're
gonna skip getting spark syrup locally
that's not gonna happen before my flight
I want to look at Sparks primary
distributed collections we'll do
everyone's favorite word count example
and then we'll rewrite our word count
example using the vectorizer yes and
this will show us that the vectorize
duty apps are really fast but also we
didn't do a great job on that design
part of the API because it's actually
surprisingly difficult to do a word
count with them and that was kind of
oops anyways we'll fix it later I'm sure
probably yeah so right um I think for
it's pretty awesome but obviously my
success is tied to the success of spark
so there are other systems which are
pretty awesome too which I make less
money on and so you should totally take
everything I say about how awesome spark
is with a grain of salt and yeah I also
write I'm also super jaded so when I say
that spark is terrible you should take
that with a grain of salt too that that
is gonna happen
so yeah spark is a general-purpose data
parallel system
it's an Apache project this is nice
because it means that different vendors
who hate each other can work together
and it's faster than hadoop mapreduce
and i really want to give a shout out to
the MapReduce community for setting such
a low bar
thank you thank you no like I mean I do
MapReduce is a wonderful tool it's great
at what it does but performance wise
they left a lot of opportunities for
improvement and it's good for one our
data gets too big for a single machine
and right so spark is not just this core
or distributed execution engine it is a
whole bunch of crap there are two
separate graph AP is conveniently and
neither of them work they compile in
Scala and I don't actually think we
expose them properly in Python ever we
have an old machine learning library and
a new machine learning library inside of
the same project that's not at all
confusing about which one to use and
that went over so well with the
community that we decided to make two
separate streaming api's as well
realistically we we just didn't want to
break the old API to run to keep
people's code working but we wanted to
take some of the like things that people
yellow us in the street when they find
out where SPARC developers and be like
ok I'm gonna fix that bug sort of um but
we were too broken a lot of people's
code if we tried to just you know
retrofitted on the old legacy EP is so
why do people come to spark MapReduce
jobs was a good reason it's taking you
know 16 hours or maybe 72 hours and
you're like I bet I could learn spark
before Mac my MapReduce job finishes
this is sometimes true um the other one
is my data frame does not fit in memory
on my cluster anymore other people are
like it definitely doesn't fit memory on
my macbook pro this is what I need
distributed computing and I will
encourage you to perhaps wait a little
longer you can buy bigger machines in
the MacBook Pro but I mean if you want
to use distributed computing at that
point I make money so that's fine I
won't discourage you that much now if
anyone's like really excited about this
and I was like I really love following
along with examples that are on slides
in notebook environments
I have the notebook I have a notebook
with the examples from today in a little
bit more of a sort of structured manner
to lead you down using the MLA api's
we're going to do a little more of the
interest of today but if you want to
follow up this is this is the place to
go and you can play with those notebooks
and tell me what's broken and the newest
version of spark because I haven't had a
chance to update it because I came out
last week okay so um the first thing
that you get when you start up spark is
you get a spark context and we can think
of this as our entry into the world we
can use this to create distributed
collections we can do this from all
sorts of different input sources from
HDFS to things that look like HDFS to s3
we can even take local files and turn
them into distributed collections this
works pretty well we can create counters
and accumulators which sound really
useful but don't actually work the way
anyone wants them to so don't use those
and yeah we can connect it to all sorts
of different backends we can connect it
to a local back-end which will just run
a sort of a simulation of a cluster on
our laptop we can connect it to a spark
cluster or we can put it on top of yarn
or your existing Hadoop infrastructure
as of about a week ago you can also put
it on top of kubernetes but that should
just I I love the Cooper know these
people and I love the kubernetes on
spark people but like it is it feels
like a v1 API and we're working on it I
I do not encourage you to run spark on
kubernetes in production that's just
gonna go real bad right so what is an
RDD it's resilient and distributed and
the resilient part is super important
right if I'm working on a single
computer right I can sort of say if this
computer fails my program is gonna fail
and that's just kind of life right but
when I have a hundred computers if I say
with one of these computers fails my job
fails then that starts to approach like
my job is never going to succeed
especially if I run on top
of you know some commodity hardware and
support takes a really different
approach to achieving this resiliency it
uses recomputation on failure so
essentially it keeps track of all of the
things you've asked it to do and if one
of the computers with information it
needs goes away it goes back and just
computes the missing piece of data the
classic MapReduce model instead writes
out the results of three different
machines and that works as well as
writing to three different machines over
a network file system works which is to
say it succeeds but it's slow and one of
the weird parts about rdd's is that
they're lazily evaluated and this is
actually like it's really super core to
how spark works and this is what we use
to build this resilience by not
executing the actions immediately as a
call different things on my distributive
collection I just built up a graph of
operations and I only execute this graph
when I'm finally forced to much like a
teenager taking out the garbage right
you ask them to take out the garbage
they say yep done that and then you go
and you checking the garbage is so there
and then the teenager eventually takes
out the garbage
in theory I don't know that never worked
on me okay so everyone loves word count
right
we're pumped for work come on yeah yeah
I'm getting like just pumping in the
back admittedly pretty sure it's
insincere it's okay so what so there are
SRC could point to a distributed file
system like HDFS it could also just be a
local file on my computer I have this
very fancy space tokenizer
works super well for English and because
I live in North America I get to pretend
that's good enough and then I go ahead
and so this this first call gives us
back an RTT right and it's important to
note that even if our input file didn't
exist here spark wouldn't complain spark
would be like cool I got you it's only
when we
they go and call save that spark will be
like oh yeah
when I said I got you what I really
meant is your file doesn't exist so no
so that's just really lovely when you're
debugging and so okay the other thing is
this is also an RDD so this words thing
here is created by taking our input data
and applying a transformation where we
take each input and we split it on
spaces and this comes into a list and
then flatmap means that it gets
flattened so this is just an RDD of all
of the words for my input and then word
categorize ever and the nice thing is
yeah these don't exist right there
they're just nodes on a graph and some
of these nodes will actually get
collapsed down together right it will
probably actually say well tokenize
these I can I can make that word in the
number one go together at the same time
I don't need to do two separate passes
over my data and this is also really
nice and I'm sorry for all of the
MapReduce jokes but this is really nice
because in other classical systems you
spend a lot of time thinking about how
to like chain all of your things
together into the minimum number of
passes over your data but SPARC does
this for us I mean at the slight cost of
not understanding what's happening with
our software but it's not like debugging
as a core part of our everyday activity
all right so this is cool because we get
pipelining that's that's laziness this
we we call the graph a directed acyclic
graph because they've wanted papers use
acronyms for lots of papers and we can
do all sorts of interesting
optimizations here there is this other
cache to actually make this dag work
right if I'm gonna recompute my data on
failure I can't have my data change on
me right so if we go back here right and
the first time we went through this like
words was one thing but then later on I
modified words but something in word
count failed I would be in a really
weird state and I wouldn't really know
what's happening
so all of these collections are
immutable and this is important and yeah
whatever
cool yay here we go we have that
color-coded recordings more exciting but
my head okay right so there's there's a
catch though right like this magic is
really cool right spark has done some
cool magical optimizations for me inside
of here but one of the things which it
hasn't done is let's say that I wanted
to do something instead of just counting
the words in my input right maybe I'm
actually like loading some log data and
I I care about finding all of my error
messages and all of my warning messages
the problem is spark is not a compiler
it is you cannot see into the future
either it doesn't have a DeLorean and so
when it gets soon as action stage right
it has no idea what's gonna come next so
all it can do is look at the graph we've
created so far and it has no idea for
any future graphs and so you really have
to help spark out because this is how
our programming model works if you want
to reuse any of your data and you have
to tell spark but this data should be
kept around rather than being thrown
away to make room for new data just to
see offender set it correctly wise say
the first line not actually evaluated to
be honest yeah so if I try to say right
yeah so if you tried to print this to
console so if you try to print lines to
console what you would see is like the
wrapper would just be RTD right and that
would contain no information for you
it's great yeah okay but whatever it
goes a lot faster than the alternative
and that's sort of the bargain that we
made with spark which was like I'm not
gonna understand how anything's gonna
work but you promise me you'll run
pretty fast most of the time and they
were like yeah sure
one of them might start up right
magic yeah magic okay so in addition to
map and flatmap there are a lot of
different things that we can do on top
of an RDD and these are things which
will give us back new rdd's and they are
lazy like a panda and so map and filter
and flat map and some of these things
probably seem really similar from the
itertools collection and that's because
they are they're just functional
programming concepts that happen to be
implemented on the distributed
collection the drawing is a little
different because if this operates on
multiple rdd's so you can join two
separate pieces of distributed data and
reduce by key is also a little bit
different because the first three can
just be done processing locally on each
machine but it reduced by key we might
not actually have all of the same
information about things all the
information about each key on the right
machine so we have to shuffle it around
and the actions are the thing which make
spark do the work and so if you were
debugging this actually a really common
pattern is to use the count action which
is kind of useless it just tells you the
number of elements but it forces spark
to do the work so if you thought that
your input file might not exist
you could call count on it right after
you'd loaded it and then spark would
actually check and see what was going on
yeah okay um and this can feel like
magic I mean not like especially good
magic but magic um but just like
anything that's magical right if people
remember like early Ruby on Rails and
how happy it was the magic has its
limitations
so we can do something that looks pretty
safe and instead it'll actually make our
cluster fall over and so we can do a bad
version for camp um and part of us is
there's this thing called group by key
which I really regret that we have her
implemented it because it sounds safe to
people who come from really any
ground besides distributed systems and
even if you come from distributed
systems it sounds pretty safe and what
happens is this will make a group and
we're used to spark making this graph
and optimizing this graph but there's
sort of a limitation to this graph this
graph can't look inside of our lambda
expressions right here we're computing a
sum but sparks graph only really knows
that we have some Python code in here so
it can't take the sum and pipeline it up
it actually creates a giant list and
then has to do this computation and this
giant list could be too big to fit in
memory and so that's unfortunate it's
not magical but we learned from some of
our mistakes with this API we were like
lambdas are awesome but maybe not
everything has to be done with a lambda
expression we can do other things and
then spark can see inside it more things
we can give spark x-ray vision all right
this was a Ford Pinto catching on fire
turns out difficult to find a Ford Pinto
on fire or photo surprisingly that's
creative common license so I applied my
photoshop skills don't actually have
Photoshop I run Linux um but you know
Google Sites same thing okay so this is
a wonderful segue into something that
claims to solve the problems that I just
showed you which is sparks dataset API
also known as sparks do deferring the
API and if you come from pandas that
sounds exciting um look do not worry dad
is a much more accurate name because I
don't look like a data frame um we get a
really smart optimizer we get better
serializers and we get window operations
and this the window operations and
multi-column multi typed aggregates are
things which are really simple to do on
single machines but really annoying to
do on distributed systems like eminently
doable it just involves writing a lot of
really fiddly code where I reversed two
things and then we get the average wrong
and I have to update my resume and
that's awkward right you never want to
be like yeah this lambda expressions why
I'm looking for a job you're next
so there's a bunch of things the
strongly-typed part doesn't actually
work in Python for pretty obvious
reasons but all of the other stuff is
pretty cool we get nice performance of
spark sequel we can actually write
inline sequel does anyone like writing
sequel that is oh don't be ashamed no no
on your sequel own it there is nothing
wrong with sequel in fact um sequel has
a lot of really nice properties when it
comes to distributed systems it is
really hard to figure out a lambda
expression it is way easier to figure
out a sequel expression right and so if
I'm trying to build an optimizer I want
to build an optimizer for something I
can understand because otherwise I
started looking at Python byte code and
trust me I've done that it took me six
weeks I'm not really okay it took me two
weeks to switch it from Python tear to
Python 3 but that's we're not two weeks
of fun those were two weeks of like
really bitter despair and then I gave up
said like whatever some bad words and
deleted some functionality and I worked
um anyways cool so I give this vendor
benchmark now admittedly I'm not like
selling you software I don't make money
that way but you should definitely take
what I say with a grain of salt as I am
a vendor that says if you use this new
thing it totally runs faster than the
old thing and this is true for computing
some random metrics that showed me this
don't worry I tried a few things until I
got the answers I wanted and that's
where the slide came from but like it's
actually really often isn't improvement
I'm just saying don't just do it and as
soon it'll get better measure it and
then double check so how is it so fast
in addition to carefully selected
benchmarks the optimizer gets some
additional information when we start
writing in the day
frame our data set API and the other
part is and I'm sorry about this one we
actually do a bunch of your computation
in the JVM behind your back I'm sorry
but it's okay because that kind of goes
faster when it works when it doesn't
work I'm really sorry but this can make
it go faster so let's look at word count
again yeah okay um so we have a very
similar loading of input data we have
spark reload why we made it longer I
don't know but this gives us back a data
frame rather than an RDD and then you
can see this starts to look a little bit
like sequel we have a select expression
[Music]
so of our flat map with our lambda
expression now the thing is we're not
going to get a lot of speed up because
it was a flat map here with the lambda
expression they can't magically start
looking inside of our flat maps but it
can look inside of our group by and our
sum and it can actually understand our
group by is just on this column and then
I'm just applying the sum to that and I
can have group by n sum and my code
probably won't fall over if the
optimizer to its job right which is
about as reassuring as anything gets in
distributed systems and so this is this
is nice but this this part is still kind
of slow right so we're gonna we're gonna
try and make it go faster we're gonna do
more word count soon I promise I know
everyone's on the edge of their seats
but what what is optimizer able to do so
one of the things that that makes PI
spark kind of slow is that we use this
serialization called pickling everyone
loves pickling right super fast
very space efficient and definitely easy
to be understood in the JVM all you have
to do is manually smash some bits
together and you can probably figure out
if it's an integer and yeah it's pretty
much where we're at right so because we
have to
work together between Python and the JVM
and spark using the pickle serializer
gave us a lot of flexibility for pretty
much handling any type of data Python
wanted to throw at us but didn't give us
a lot of information about the data we
were working on so we use a different
serialize ER now and it's one where we
actually understand the data in both and
don't worry we have a new serializer
that will fix even more problems coming
soon that's in spark 2003 and yeah it it
gives it a lot more compact
representation so um
group I returns a group data a frame or
a group data set if they're working at
Scala and it has a bunch of built in
aggregates and if none of the bills and
aggregates are the ones that you want
you can still write your custom
aggregation with a bunch of lambda
expressions but it'll keep you from just
calling the sum right I'll keep you from
doing that thing which looks really safe
but is actually super dangerous and
there's there's built-in shortcuts if
you want to go look at the long list
it's over there right okay
now oh this is this one Java could
pretend that's not here pretend this
import statement isn't here I'm sorry I
have to talk to JVM people too
it's okay actually I just get rid of the
import statement Python and so we can
group by age compute the minimum number
of hours per week or we could compute
multiple summary statistics at the same
time yay I didn't have to write a reduce
by key with three separate tracking
variables this is so exciting it is so
incredibly basic but but where he must
spark for long enough will make you so
excited for simple things where you're
like yes I can compute the average of
two numbers oh and I mean like people
taking like pure science classes they're
just like uh-huh right now
I'm like no no no it's really cool and
then normally that's what's fun I'm
alone in the coffee shop but that's also
why I travel
anyways moving on to so I promised you
that this thing is going to save you
right and I'm probably trying to
convince you to rewrite a bunch of code
you already have right especially since
there were a bunch of people who already
seem to work with spark it would be a
disservice if I did not tell you where I
know data frames are bad and one of them
is iterative algorithms so if you're
gonna try and build a machine learning
algorithm or graph algorithm on top of
data frames they're gonna behave really
poorly which is why we built our new
machine learning and graph algorithms on
top of data frames yeah that's not a
joke um or is but like a really intense
one with a lot of software behind it um
thankfully there is a little escape
hatch where we can just go oh yo I just
it's been great knowing your data frames
but I'm just I'm just gonna go back to
rdd's it's like don't worry I'll be back
I'll be back but essentially if you're
gonna do machine learning you're gonna
end up using rdd's i'm to the side out
of it
has anyone had to tune a spark job in
production no one you are all very lucky
people essentially the other thing that
you'll get with sparks evil and data
frames and data sets and whatever else
we decide to call it is a whole bunch
more knobs to tune and yeah so the guide
list of knobs for spark doesn't fit on
like four pages and the sequel ones are
a separate collection so start buying
your ops team brownies cookies whatever
it is they like to butter them up for
the future of deploying this into
production okay I promised that I was
going to show you machine learning and
so sports machine learning API the new
one that we built on top of data frames
which is bad for machine learning is
very psychic learn inspired I pretty
much looked at this I could learn api's
and said ooh that was a much better idea
let's just do that but then we decided
to make some other
for decisions and so are our stages are
broken down to either estimators or
transformers estimators have to see data
to be fit and once they're fit they
produce transformers transformers can be
the result of fitting an estimator like
I can fit a naive Bayes model and this
will give me and I sorry I continue now
as estimator which will give me a nice
model or they can just be like purely
stateless things like hashing TF or our
good friend the space to organizer hmm
now data prep looks well honestly if
your data prep looks like this you're
probably doing something like a cowgirl
competition or training on M NIST CSV
which is which is legit the important
thing to note is this is like the
simplest data prep that you can do but
we can essentially see that we can
create different stages and we can put
them together into a pipeline most
likely you're gonna have to do a lot of
data cleaning there are a bunch of tools
in this part to do data cleaning that it
is unfortunately a topic unto itself
and it's not complete without a natural
decision tree so we're going to go ahead
and make a little decision tree
classifier and then we say that our
pipeline does these three things and
then I go ahead and I find out fit fits
all of my components it gives me back a
model and that's great the only problem
is sometimes fitting these things could
take maybe days if you're on ms-dos CSV
probably not days but you know this can
take a really long time and I don't know
if you noticed we've got this label
column as a string in this future column
as a string this isn't being picked up
I'm typing this in manually so the odds
that I eventually mistake my label
column one day and my final step will be
training my decision tree classifier
after doing all sorts of other work is
pretty high I don't know what the odds
are for you maybe your pay more
attention to your jobs but a good trick
is to run this on smaller data rather
big data first just sample your data run
it through make sure this pipeline works
then run it on the big one otherwise you
will eventually come in the next day to
find out that you wasted an entire
evening
um admittedly if your salary I know
okay so I've alluded to this a little
bit that spark is is in the job at JVM
for the most part and so how do we
actually make this work how do we
actually make Python and spark talk
together so we use hyper Jay pickling
JSON and we actually not use something
else called Apache arrow and a healthy
dose of magic to glue all of these
together these can be kind of slow arrow
is faster than the other ones but if
anyone are there any our users in the
house please don't feel ashamed okay
lovely well no after the sequel thing I
just want you know it's alright that you
use different technologies besides
Python the right tool for the right job
right or whichever twelve pays me the
most and so spark are uses the same
magic so the stuff you learn here is
pretty much what everyone else ties to
and so this architecture diagram in
addition to illustrating that I don't
work with a graphic designer can show
you that on our sort of driver program
which is like our laptop or the Japanese
to our cluster or Jupiter kernels
running we have a Python process talking
to the JVM over sockets this is kind of
slow i Forge as well so but it turns out
it doesn't matter that much because
normally all we're doing is telling the
JVM what we want done we're not
transferring a lot of data here all of
the data transfer happens here which is
where we use UNIX pipes yes and as as
mentioned in the front row of audience
that is slower yay
also whoops so not the best design
decision but working on it
working on it um we also we use sockets
in some cases
but our data is essentially copied from
the JVM into Python in Bacchus and so
naturally that is not fast um but we're
working on it and we actually made
substantial improvements a week ago that
are actually available to be deployed
into production if you're looking for a
new job and so that's the present faster
interchange so it's technically released
it since part 2.3 it is the first
release with this in it so it will
probably have a lot of bugs notably I'm
pretty sure it doesn't handle date time
data correctly so please don't put dates
through it unless you really like UTC if
everything's in UTC I am so jealous and
my work the other nice thing is that
arrow in addition to being understood by
both Python and Java is also understood
by the like fancy people who make the
CUDA language and so if you've got some
GPU acceleration going on for your deep
learning we got you um I don't know
probably you've got a bunch of
self-driving cars out here right you
probably have to do deep learning on
GPUs whatever um in the Bay Area and
normally you do deep learning on GPUs
because you're trying to raise more
money not because you don't want to kill
people
that's sort of optional ok yeah so um it
is possible that like it is in spark 2.3
it's an open source project I can't
guarantee you that it is like the future
forever but things look really promising
the early benchmarks from the vendors
who try and sell you things are quite
promising this is a benchmark from one
of my former employers and you can see
it could run 200 times faster more
politely that is a carefully selected
benchmark and I applaud their choice and
it is true it could run 200 times faster
it is unlikely to but I think you will
see a real performance speed ops Envy
like 2x 3x
admittedly I am also a vendor so please
double check my god feelings with your
own actual real code okay so what about
if we wanted to actually write some UDF
so we all know that python is great for
numerical computation so I decided the
best demo UDF was adding the number one
so Jade I mean you don't want to trust
the JVM to add two integers together I'm
more I'm going back so um here I can I
can write this pandas UDF I tell it that
is an integer and I tell it it's a
scholar scaler and that I add X and the
number one yeah this will run a lot
faster mostly because all of your work
before was simply copying the data
around you weren't spending any time
really adding this number one so this
might get 3x faster but you might also
actually want to do things with group
data right this is this is very much not
group data all right I don't have it
sorted in any way but you might have
have switched to the fancy you know
group by key on data frames in which
case we use this grouped map structure
and then this PDF or pandas dataframe is
going to represent an individual group
and we can go ahead and on this and
that's really awesome too it goes faster
I promise this is the one which goes 200
times faster I really don't know how
they got that number but it's okay
but it seems like people aren't super
buying this so we're gonna go back to
work count it's like I knew everyone
count oh yeah my original plan was to
use Spacey but then it didn't fit on us
fine but the important part is we could
actually put some interest inside of
here the only really sad part is that
this is really not very elegant code
right if you think about our previous
word count example like you could print
that on a t-shirt and maybe be like you
what's up this is cool or at least you
could in San Francisco because we got
really low standards for fashion but
like if you put this on a t-shirt people
will be like ok so
if the string is not none I make a new
data frame and why wait what
and so it turns out we did a bad job in
our scalar example we required that the
inputs and the outputs be of the same
size so when we want to tokenize things
for each input we might want to produce
zero or more outputs and so we can't use
this which is really the API we should
be using or I mean it's the API which
looks nice instead we can use this weird
group thing because we don't have that
prescription and the group data and
please don't actually do this work out
this word count will run slower than the
other word count I attempt to me you go
faster actually made it slower that's
life
because we actually have to do a group
by so that we can have some group data
and it turns out doing a group by causes
a shuffle and that's just like I'm
instead of saving myself so I have I've
reduced the amount of time it takes to
copy the data from the JVM to Python for
the cost of copying my data to different
JVM
across a network and it turns out that
that's much slower the network is slower
than even pickling so this was a bad
idea and we got to revisit this so that
this word count can also be a happy word
count and then we'll have three happy
word counts anyways okay so before I
leave you with with spark I want to
point out that everything else is
terrible too and in different ways but a
lot of other systems looked at sparks
design decisions and for some reason
we're not horrified and said you know
what I will do that too and I'm just
like no no um some of them looked at it
and said I think it's missing XML and
for those people I say perhaps not but
it's okay um mm-hmm
your alternative his pickle objects
being parsed in the JVM I understand his
bridge and there's there's another
option - yeah
one option which actually did not look
at spark or well it did look at spark
and it looked at spark in my oh no no no
no no that that was a bad idea we are
not doing that it looked at some of
spark I'm like whoo I like distributed
computation but I don't like the JVM the
JVM is not my friend and it's actually
it gives you a data frame interface
which looks a lot more like a panda's
data frame it's written in pure Python
which means that we don't have this
memory copy challenge well I mean pure
Python so there's a bunch of C code I'm
probably a little bit of Fortran just
keep things going it's a big problem
though is because it's pure Python how
many people actually work in 100% Python
shops okay yeah so that was not a lot of
people and that's that's sort of the
challenge especially in big data shops
we tend to be working with other people
who produce data in formats that really
aren't suited to being parsed by Python
directly right now our options for
posting park' data not so good and
that's sort of where desk is there's
also ray which is a similar project from
my research lab I don't know which one's
better neither of them pay me so I don't
really care
beam is produced by a large number of
people including my employer so they of
course deserve a slide it essentially
looked at Google's design sorry it yeah
it essentially looked at sparks design
and said you know what I'm just gonna
use a bunch of internal Google
technology I mean open source but I'm
gonna use a bunch of Google technology
instead of pickling and that'll probably
go better and it turns out kinda um but
not the greatest cuz we [ __ ] up some
other parts of our design but if you
want to come help us fix them for free
it's an open source project and you can
totally do that
more seriously I think like if you're if
you're interested in working in a Python
project it's kind of neat and it also
doesn't support Python 3 they meant to
fix that over the holidays that did not
happen
especially those people keep writing
more Python 2 code is really hard to get
rid of once it's in your project okay
and I want to close out with the final
option is there's a really good chance
that you don't need any of this stuff
you might just be time with
multi-processing um and actually this is
kind of nice um desk notably supports
multi processing as a back-end you don't
have to run it on the cluster
you can tell tasks to run it and sort of
multi-process Modi spark also to some
degree has a local mode tasks local mode
is a lot more lightweight and there's
less overhead involved because you
really don't need the JVM involved when
you're just running on one machine right
JVM really is bringing nothing to the
table at that point but on the other
hand you know when it comes time to
scale mm-hmm a little more hands-on okay
right more important I have a new book
you can buy several copies of it don't
waste your money on it if you're a
student but if you work for a
corporation and you have an expense
account
it is an excellent gift for people that
do not know how to return things to
Amazon
also I recommend having your cat sit in
the box because then the cat will pee on
the book and you probably can't sell it
on the second-hand market and this will
keep the prices high and and cats do
love the box that the book comes in I
have at least one testimonial I will be
talking at a bunch of other places if
you want an excuse to come visit London
I'll be at PI data London and also Kefka
summit London and just right out of
London I apparently I'm going to London
okay hmm so that's pretty much it I have
a flight in one hour in 30 minutes wait
1 hour and 25 minutes I I can do like a
question or two and then I'm going to
hop in a the thing car
wait didn't you raise your hand for not
using spark yes so I mean right so if i
want--is has different defaults and the
sparks equal defaults as I sort of
skimmed over our kinda crap 200
partitions is probably not enough for
what you're doing and so most likely do
what you need to do if you wanted to use
spark in your workload there's a tuning
guide written by my former coworker Anja
Peeta there's there's other things and
essentially it'll just lead you down a
flowchart of which magical knobs you
need to to and based on what your data
so it looks like I have this like kind
of out there plan of making something
that'll automatically turn those knobs
but I'm sure it'll get it wrong for the
first year so yeah I mean most likely
it's tuning without seeing your data
it's hard to say yeah yeah I know that
sounds about right
no like I mean if you were doing a join
like that and you only had to partition
200 partitions like that's just that's
just gonna fail you just have to up the
number and yeah I mean if you buy this
high-performance
spark book on Amazon you too can find
some magic knobs to turn but you can
also go look at my co-workers like
github
so you can use so I think the the new in
my library I probably should have
clarified this so thank you for asking
that question you can totally use data
frames with it it's just if you want to
write your own ML algorithm under the
hood you will not want to use data
frames inside of your algorithm so
you're gonna want to go you'll take in a
data frame but then you'll take this
escape hatch in the RD deal and when you
get to the order a portion of your code
and this will allow the optimizer to do
all kinds of things with like if you're
only reading specific pieces of data
like narrow down the data which is
actually going to get that the RTD but
you know when it comes time to do your
order of algorithm you really need to do
it in rdd's for now honestly I don't
know I'm that's gonna get fixed
the sequel optimizer is like this giant
collection of high quality code that I
don't want to understand like it's it's
it's really good but it's just like whoa
I did I did not do a PhD in databases I
will leave this to people who did my
questions so maybe the segue is we we
are giving away a signed copy of
Holden's book today like the first
person to answer this question will will
get this book and the question is what
is the name of a stuffed animal anyway
you know if nobody knows you kid you can
look it up especially if you follow
Holden on on Twitter and you can find me
I will be holding on to this book free
from cat I probably should stop making
that joke
[Applause]